president biden had backed a vaccine
waiver during the 2020 presidential
campaign
and in recent weeks his team has held a
series of discussions with
representatives from the pharmaceutical
sector
[Music]
today it was a u.s trade representative
catherine ty who formally made the
announcement
these extraordinary times and
circumstances of call for
emergency measures she tweeted the u.s
supports the waiver of protection on
covert 19 vaccines
to help end the pandemic and will
actively participate in wto negotiations
to make that happen in the past the us
and other countries had opposed any
waiver of intellectual property rights
the white house press secretary
explaining the change in position
clearly as these decisions are weighed
we take intellectual property incredibly
seriously
and we also though are in the midst of a
historic global pandemic which requires
a range of
creative solutions and we're looking at
it through that prism
while the pharmaceutical industry had
argued strongly against the waiver
there were many in president biden's own
party who insisted that he uphold his
campaign promise
blocking access to vaccines is any
humanitarian
it's any diplomatic and it weakens
american influence for the good on the
global stage
and while the biden administration
continues to step up
efforts to vaccinate as many americans
as possible
the potential impact of its decision on
the global stage
cannot be understated i think it's an
incredible moment
in american history what president biden
has
essentially said to the world is this is
a moment
for the global community to come
together to form a global response to
this pandemic
it is unprecedented it is historic
and i have to say that it is one that is
going to change the course of this
pandemic
the message too from the biden
administration
that while the pandemic continues to
rage in countries like
india americans cannot consider
themselves
safe mike hanna al jazeera
washington